[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this video
we're breaking down the last of us part
two I think this is gonna be a highly
controversial game that will no doubt be
debated far into the future there's a
lot to unpack from it and yet throughout
this video we're just gonna be going
through its storyline ending and the
meaning behind it obviously there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you don't
anything ruined that I highly recommend
that you turn off now it's been almost
impossible to avoid leaks on this thing
but if you've managed to do so then I
don't want to ruin your first time
seeing how things play out if you enjoy
this video then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
the Last of Us part 2 okay so in order
to fully understand the storyline and
general meaning behind the series we
have to travel back to the first game
and talk about the thematic elements of
that The Last of Us part 1 was very much
about breaking a cycle and this was
shown predominantly through the eyes of
Joel when the quarter set out break
first happened Joel tried to flee with
his brother Tommy and daughter Sarah
however she was killed by a member of
the military and Joel spent the next
chapter of his life grieving and angry
at the world a feeling of hope came back
when he was given the task of a scoring
ally to the fireflies and she was very
much a young girl much like his daughter
who was actually revealed to be immune
to the virus the fireflies claimed to be
able to extract the Cure from her but
upon arriving at their facility geo
learned that she would die during the
process rather than go through the same
thing again in which a member of the
military would literally once more take
his daughter away
Joel broke the cycle killed the majority
of the fireflies and surgeons and then
fled with Ellie Joel lied to her and
told her that they weren't able to
extract the Cure and Ellie Boyett they
returned to Joel's brother Tommy and
this is where the opening of Part two
picks up now before we get into the full
breakdown we have to bear in mind this
idea of cycles and breaking them though
I don't think that the Last of Us part
two pulls off the theme as well as the
prior entry and I don't really think it
does it that well at all
I'm gonna remove my personal opinion
from things for the meantime and just
discuss the main elements of the
storyline and what they actually mean
during the game there are several
perspective changes and the events of
the storyline jump back and forth
between characters so to keep things
streamlined I'll try and do everything
in the order that makes the most sense
there's also a number of things from the
trailers that will change for the game
and it's clear that they tried to hide a
certain death as best they could
obviously let me know your thoughts on
the storyline and the comments as we go
through it but there's a lot to talk
about and the idea of an eye for an eye
or leading to both people losing their
sight is laced throughout the plot and
we open with Joel telling Tommy the
truth about what happened as he cleans
up his guitar tommy is clearly horrified
by what his brother has done but after
Joel explains that he saved her life
he slowly sees things from his
perspective and understands why I took
the path he did without condoning it
Joel visits Ally and gifts her his
guitar playing her the song future days
which somewhat becomes his theme and
ties massively into the end the idea of
cycles is very much highlighted by the
game opening on this image of the guitar
as it closes on it - hinting at things
coming full circle before a character
breaks away from them we then get a huge
four year time jump and alongside Ellie
were introduced to Jessie and Dena a
pair that have recently broken up Ellie
and Dena clearly have a thing for one
another and a kiss between the pair
eventually leads to homophobia being
thrown their way by a bartender
Joel stepped in to save Ellie and wheel
in throughout the story that Ellie
actually journey to the hospital in
which the fireflies were stationed at in
the first game he or she discovered the
truth and upon encountering Joel he
admitted what really happened this
breaks her and though she returns to
their home in Jackson the relationship
between the two is clearly almost beyond
repair
Ellie is mad because she believes her
life could have meant something but
that's all been dashed away because of
one selfish person that didn't want to
lose his daughter now it's through Joel
saving her that she perhaps starts to
see things from his perspective and
though she's angry in her eyes she's
lost a father just like how joel has
lost her this idea of daughters losing
their father and what that can do to
someone is reflected in one of the
biggest surprises in the game that is a
be a playable character who is part of
the Washington Liberation Front
lwf for short this is the biggest
bait-and-switch since Metal Gear Solid 2
and you spend a lot of time in her shoes
we learned that Abby's father was
actually one of the surgeons that was
going to operate on Ellie and save the
planet
however Joel killed him and thus she
spent years building up a body in order
to hunt him down and get revenge
at one point Joel and Tommy actually
come across Abby and save her life
however the vendetta that she carries
over weighs this and she made his Joel
by shooting his leg with a shotgun and
she then plays mario golf on his head
Ellie arrives to watch this happening in
front of her and thus this mirrors Abby
discovering her father dead several
years prior Abby and Ellie are of course
similar sounding names and the two go on
quests that parallel one another in many
ways both have pregnant members of their
group a sort of love triangle as thick
and they both lost their father to a
person that was twisted to act a certain
way by the world now many people I'm
guessing will absolutely hate playing as
Abby after all we watch her murder one
of the greatest video game characters of
all time even after he saved her life I
didn't actually have this plot point
rune for me by the leaks so I was kind
of expecting it but yeah I'd love to
hear your thoughts on how you took it
now an important point to note is that
Ellie plays jazz guitar throughout the
game and it's clear that her at least
this is keeping the character alive in
some form or another
the idea of Joel and Ellie's memories of
him really drive her quest for revenge
and she slowly hunts down Abby's group
murdering them one by one she learns
that one of the members was pregnant and
after taking them out decides that this
quest for a bench you might not benefit
anyone in the long run we learned
throughout the story that Dena is
pregnant with Jessi's child and a thing
at this point it becomes too much for
Ellie
however the eye for an eye theme
continues and Abby shows up shoots Tommy
murders Jessie and fights Ellie almost
beating her to death
this is switched at the end of the game
when the roles are reversed and Ellie
and Abby are very much opposites of one
another
experiencing the same emotions and
driving forces at different times just
as Abby is about to kill Ellie Dena
intervenes but Abby best sir - she
almost slits her throat but the
character levy arrives and tells her to
stop it's here that we get a
switch to the game character there
you've probably grown to love to hate at
this point and we see things solely
through the shoes of a bee I kind of
gloss over this as it just sort of tells
the tale of the above from the opposite
side with some extra sex scenes in there
that yeah these are gonna get meme done
for the rest of our life so get used to
seeing this in your dreams you your wet
dreams anyway now the main point of this
is to put you in a bee's shoes and to
make you try and understand why she does
the things that she does you'll have to
decide for yourself whether this is
successful or not as I can see multiple
people having completely different
opinions on it we learned that levy was
actually a member of the Sara fights
that was hated amongst a group for being
trans the Sara fights or other scars
because I can't be bothered saying Sara
fights anymore are very much set in
their ways and reject all forms of
modern society in favor of tradition
thus they hate Levy and he fled from his
mother with his sister Yara now it was
leaked that Abby was a trans character
and his spoilers however I do think that
wires got crossed and it's actually levy
that is Levy and his sister save Abby's
life at one point and a bond is formed
between the group levies worried that
things will happen to their mother back
home on scars Island and this leads to
him returning his mother a devout member
of the scars attempts to kill Lev and
thus he murders her in self-defense this
sort of ties into the themes of the game
and to me levy represents the person
that was rejected by their parent which
juxtaposes how Abby and Elly were
accepted by theirs and losing them made
them set out on a quest for revenge Yara
is killed not long after and the pair
returned to their base which is where
they find the aftermath of Ally's attack
on the aquarium
Abby sets out on the path to get revenge
and thus we bring things the same point
in which lever from killing Deena now
this is where the leaks went up to and
according to them this is how the game
ended that isn't the case and after Abby
spares them we do another time jump one
year later we pick up with Elly and
Deena living on a farm together just
outside of Jackson Deena had a baby and
the pair are raising JJ together which
yeah I'm sure you can work out what
those initials mean Ellie is completely
torn apart by Joel's death and even
though she lives a peaceful life she's
suffering from PTSD it's here that we
discover that Tommy actually survived
the gunshot wound and one day he brings
information on where Abby is located
tommy is clearly still hung up on
getting revenge and the frustration at
being unable to achieve this has pretty
much ruined his life Tommy wants a be
dead but Ellie talks him out of it and
it finally seems that she's learned the
path of revenge only leads to more
misery
Confucius famously said before you
embark on a journey of revenge dig two
graves this means that if you're gonna
go out and get revenge on someone you
need to realize that things can only
really go one way now this is what
frustrates me about the storyline as
it's clearly signposted at several
points and just as it seems like Ellie
is about to let things go she instead
decides to go back down this dark road
Dena realizes this and gives her an
ultimatum to either stay with her and a
child or to head out and try and kill
Abby which could also lead to her own
death Ellie just can't escape the memory
of Joel's murder though and she goes
after Abby tearing her family apart
elsewhere we see things through the eyes
of a bee who is with levy on the search
for the fireflies in Santa Barbara
they're captured by a group known as the
Rattlers who to manage to capture Ellie
during her hunt for them absolutely love
this scene and Ellie manages to turn the
tables from them by using her immunity
to make it so that one of the captors is
bitten by clicker before killing the
other after he tells her we're happy
years this is where the game starts to
wind down and we head into the finale
Ellie runs the gauntlet and fights her
way to Abby who we see strung up with
lemons and pillars she's a shadow of a
former self and clearly has been put
through the wringer which paints her in
a much more sympathetic light Ellie cuts
Abby down and almost lets things go but
the memory of Joel continues to plague
her mind the to go head-to-head with one
another with Ellie forcing her to fight
due to holding a knife to lovey's neck
Abby who is at death's door doesn't put
up much of a fight but she manages to
bite Ellie's fingers off it looks like
it hurt but the fight is still pretty
one-sided and Ellie almost drowned sir
before deciding to break the cycle Ellie
let's Abby live and with leb the to sail
off into the sunset or it's more it's
more fog than sunset more than anything
now I have seen a lot of people roll
their eyes at this
saying that Ellie has come all this way
killed hundreds of people and yet she
won't kill the one person that she left
awake of bodies to get to however I
think at this moment that Ellie realizes
this cycle of revenge will lead to her
losing more than she wants to give up I
would imagine that she would spare Lev
as Lev saved her and Dena's life however
leb would no doubt grow up hating Ellie
for killing happy and it's safe to say
that the cycle will continue once more
similar to Joel saving his surrogate
daughter from death at the end of the
first game which juxtaposed the opening
Holly is breaking the cycle of violence
that only goes one way so though I can
see why people are angry at it in the
context of the story I do think it works
with the way that the events happen that
doesn't mean that it's really a happy
ending though and the game very much
continues with its bleak and our tone
for the final scene Ellie returns home
to find Dena and JJ gone along with what
made their house a home all that's left
of her possessions and the guitar that
Joel gave her in the opening Ali
attempts to play future days the song
that was the theme of Joel however due
to her now missing her fingers she's
unable to fully do it we then get a
flashback to the night before Joel's
death and see that the two did have a
conversation that laid it all out on the
table at least stated that she was going
to try and forgive him for what he did
but of course we know that this closure
was robbed from her Ellie puts the
instrument down and walks off likely
looking for Dena and we closed out on
the guitar similar to how the game
opened this shot of her walking away
from this item clearly shows the
symbolism of her walking away from the
memory of Joel something that had
haunted her and ultimately led her going
down a dark path Ellie has left behind
the idea of Joel and freed herself of
the burden of revenge however it's also
a sad ending because the song in some
ways was carrying the memory of the
character and in setting out on a final
quest for revenge
she lost her fingers and thus cannot
pass on his legacy it to cost her her
family and this final quest when she
should have let things go ultimately
destroyed her life however that she did
do the right thing in the end even if it
came with loss now going forward I do
think that the franchise will likely
take the focus from Ellie and probe
Center around a bian Lev as they make
their way together as the sort of new
Joel and Ellie Abby is the sort of
standing for Joel as she's looking after
a child which of course comes in the
form of laughs there are a lot of
avenues that the story could go and I'm
still unsure exactly how I feel about
the story I think it's something I need
to have marinate and and sort of digest
over the next coming days a little more
famously said that it's up to the author
to give people what they want and know
what they need and yeah let's be honest
not many people wanted this story to go
like this however this is what we got
and thus we kind of have to take it for
what it is I think that time will tell
how the story is accepted I'm not really
sure about the character motivations as
there were several times that they could
have walked away but didn't leading to
as sometimes frustrating narrative
overall that is the way things happen
though and the way that I believe the
creative team have meant the ending to
play out how you interpret it is up to
you but make sure you leave your
thoughts below on whether you hated it
or liked it for what it was I'm gonna
give the game some breathing room and
probably drop a review on the gameplay
later next week
once I've just had a time to go over in
my head so definitely keep an eye out
again if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown on white
Thanos could return to the MCU which is
gonna be linked at the end you want to
support the channel from his letter it's
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate you it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come check yourself
in the show either follow us that heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below every month we
give away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this month
he can win the MCU infinitely saga box
set and all you have to do is comment on
a video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos he
comment on the more you've a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of July in the cell be shipped
out from then to ever get to the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part with all out the way thank you for
sticking until the end
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time Jess
[Music]
[Music]